So now you should be able to take the steps that we just went through
and swap out your skeletal meshes to actually see the procedural rigging in action.
And if you build out your rig in a more segmented way,
this is going to allow you to customize the look of each of the controls for each of your body parts
so that you get a more suitable control setup for your characters.
And just as a recap of the course,
we went over the basic understandings of what procedural rigging means,
and some of the common nodes and functions available to get started with your own procedural rig.
And then we saw this in action,
taking a look at how we might create controls in two slightly different ways
with the spawn control node and the control stack function.
You should now be able to take this information forwards into your own projects
and start building your own procedural rigs.
So thank you for your time, and thank you for attending the course,
and best of luck with your own procedural rigging.